There are a few canned materials that 3JS provides. You can have a diffuse
surface, a glossy surface, and a reflective surface. You can make objects
transparent. You can even apply textures. In this unit we'll start by digging a
bit deeper into the graphics pipeline. One important element of the modern GPU
is that significant parts of its pipeline can be programmed to do whatever we
want. This is particularly compelling for displaying materials. You can use a
wide variety of equations to simulate how a surface looks. With this ability to
fully control the illumination model, you can create a wider and wider range of
substances as you learn more techniques. You can create objects that look
refractive like glass, or semitransparent and hollow. You can make objects that
have unusual optical properties. Once you get into illumination models and
shader programming the world takes on a slightly different look. I know myself
when I look at some unusual mineral or beautiful wood grain I think, hm, how
many shader instructions could I do that in?